Backstreet Boys singer AJ McLean is in
full support of his daughter changing
her name from Ava to Elliot in an
interview with People magazine McLean
revealed that his daughter came to him
one day and told him she wanted a name
change
at first AJ says he wondered if the name
change was leading to identifying as
transgender but soon realized it was
mostly based on personal preference
explaining that his daughter said Dad I
just feel like my name is not that
unique and not that original and there's
a lot of Ava's at dance and a lot of
avas at school
from there the singer just knew that if
his daughter wanted it that way that he
would fully support her
AJ revealed his thoughts on the matter
by simply stating it is her body it's
her name it's her everything and
continued by adding whatever reasoning
it is that's hers and I'm going to
support it a million percent the singer
has always been an ally and supporter of
the lgbtq plus Community but even
recently being crowned the winner of
RuPaul's secret celebrity drag race
congratulations you're a winner baby
thank you thank you
to the entire drag Community for taking
me in under your wing and allowing me to
just be me so thank you so it comes as
no surprise to see him being a fully
supportive parent adding whatever
Journey both my girls have I will be in
their Corner a million percent my wife
will be in their corner and support them
whatever their path is and whatever
their journey is that's just the family
we are
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos